we're going to get started thank you for
coming today and last installment of the
lecture series for the for commodities
class we have back with us Kevon or go
to lab from the World Wildlife Fund and
also Diane Stephenson from CSC sugar and
Charlene Broder soon from Mondelez
international I'm gonna let them talk a
little bit about their backgrounds and
then we'll head into a discussion of
sugarcane supply chains good afternoon
nice to be here I am a Diane Stevenson I
am the director of sustainability for
CSC sugar located in fearful County in
New Canaan Connecticut is just our
corporate office there we have five mini
sugar refineries around the United
States and packing and blending
operations in Mexico five years ago I
came on board a CSC sugar basically as a
in research and development I have a
bachelor's degree in food science from
the University of Illinois and a
master's in food science from Cornell
and I have on an MBA from University of
Connecticut in my last degree was up the
road here I actually have an m.div from
from Yale and I'm Dane Minister so you
wonder how life happens to people and so
you're all kind of the beginning of your
careers you never know what's gonna
happen is the time goes on I was
actually serving on my church as the
associate minister and a member of the
church own this sugar company and on a
mission trip on Paul met my husband and
he was looking to expand his company me
did someone to do IT so hire my husband
as his director of IT and at a corporate
event found out that I it was also a
food scientist and he hired me to
consult to help him develop a process to
basically decolorize
sugar basically they're bringing a lot
of sugar in from Mexico and I'm gonna
tell you the story because it's just how
the business model starts at the same
time human human beings work together to
create things the spread between Mexican
Standard which is a darker colored sugar
that is pretty much table sugar in
Mexico similar to those little packets
of raw sugar that you see in stores and
refined sugar was about you know 12
cents a pound and so he figured that he
could refine sugar for four to five
cents a pound you know if he can make a
margin of five cents a pound on a lot of
sugar it's a lot of money so the whole
motivation of this was very a very
short-term one so I was given the charge
to develop a villain Sibley low-cost
methodology of decolorizing sugar for
the US market to make liquid sugar we
weren't gonna read your annual a tour we
evaporate anything he had some small
small market already in it in that
business so as time went on because we
were developing the process I started
wondering why why do we make liquid
sugar water white that fits into sprite
or 7up and so basically the industry had
developed into a one-size-fits-all model
of liquid sugar that was very white and
so we actually had a birthday Tiffany
moment and I believe it was April 2009
to come to the this is a food processing
industry it's not you know consumer
goods was they darker color liquid sugar
that was much much more energy efficient
and environmentally sound so that's how
the company more or less went green that
really and that intentionally but kind
of by side stories and and economics at
a time when consumers were starting to
really pay more attention to to these
things a lot of companies you know
Walmart McDonald's Unilever had come out
sustainability plans where they were
looking for partners and
and cocaine you know suppliers that
would meet their sustainability
initiatives so is the company crew they
and we were met
positively in the marketplace with this
new ingredient basically becoming a crew
very rapidly and now that whole division
is out in Denver with a new boss and new
group of people leaving me behind in New
Canaan so a year ago to forward this
story of sustainability I became the
director of sustainability for the
company to basically communicate the
importance of not just be
environmentally side of it but also
ethical sourcing many of our customers
and sharable much talk about a lot more
than I do are very concerned about where
their food comes from who's growing it
how old are they is it safe and is it
not going to create brand risk so being
in the middle of the supply chain they
really gave me an end user you know food
processors who really can't get sugar
pretty much in the US without going
through a refiner that's pretty much how
it goes raw sugar is milled in in warm
climates and brought in by chef and
trained into the United States whereas
we find into into white sugar so we
become the middleman the story really is
that as a middle person and in training
organization everyone's very interested
in short in short term gain which is
basically why the hope is it started in
the first place but sustainability and
changing social dynamics of countries
and in societies is a long long-term
story so I just just wanted to basically
give the message that you know you don't
know where you might be someday but I
can attest the bring out to the fact
that Yale has such a strong message and
I know during my stay here that my my
vision of caring about the world and the
people in it
become it was greatly strengthened and
so your words and you know where you go
in life you know you guys are a little
like we've called the tree huggers I
don't know you'll just talking to the
choir I'm going to realize that but
there's a lot of people aren't in the
point and so I commend you for the work
that you will be doing Kevin Ware's like
World Wildlife Fund I was here last week
so I'll just be brief and for the record
on TV a manager sugar cane work around
the world and develop field programs for
our bilateral partnerships with
companies and also serve on the board
bongsook row which Diane also serves on
thanks I am Cheryl inbred ursin and I've
worked for a Mondelez international
which is a new name for a company that
carried a few different names of the
past couple of years I actually started
about 12 years ago with Cadbury and
Cadbury was acquired by Kraft Foods
Kraft Foods went through a split last
year and so there's a Kraft Foods in
North America grocery and then there's
Mondelez international which which is
really a holding company for all of the
global biscuits chocolates and gums and
I guess to back up even how I ended up
in the role I'm the sustainable AG and
ethical sourcing manager for the
Americas region we have a small focused
sustainability team within the whole
global corporation one of us for each
global region where we operate
I joined Cadbury back twelve years ago
because it was a company that that
really had a focus on human rights at
the core of everything it did after my
undergrad I had been a missionary and
crew and I came back wanting to start a
non-profit import company and learn
business while doing it and and had
taken a trip over to Romania after
communism fell saw that Apple farmers
were just seeking out ways that they
could compete in an international market
after calm
ISM and and they said you know thanks
for the food supplies and clothing but
we really need someone to help us to you
know learn the efficiencies and increase
our infrastructure and and so when I
came back I had a call from mots which
was owned by Cadbury at the time here in
Stamford Connecticut for a job so I
didn't care what the job was I took it
in hopes of trying to get someone to buy
the apples from Romania and long story
after twelve years I ended up in
obviously in the procurement division
and how and where we buy things became
such a critical component and key
decision maker that we you know it took
a while but once the senior I guess
leadership really took notice that the
criticality of knowing where you're
getting your core raw materials from and
an assuring that there's human rights at
the foundation and from their
stewardship of the environment and
support for the you know whole
socio-economic yes impact of what you're
buying and where it's something that's
an inherent part of how we do business
yes I can say a little bit about sugar
so I'm responsible for any of the
initiatives are on our sustainable AG
commodities across the Americas and part
of that includes sugar sugar cane
especially and worked with WWF and CS
sugar and on how we can all work
together in our value chains to actually
have a transformational impact rather
than just doing our own siloed type of
initiatives on the ground
so I think one of the key challenges I
think when we're going to our suppliers
we're not necessarily the biggest
customer and so what we're asking of
them has to be consistent with what
they're hearing from some of our other
competitors in the industry so it's very
important that we are delivering a
consistent message and where we're
really focused on on what what is really
needed so when we looked at I think I'll
just go right into this whole Bonsu CRO
is their knowledge about on super ok so
going into bond super on this this gave
us a platform to be able to go to our
supply base and in a consistent manner
let them know that this helps us to
assure that they're upholding human
rights environmental stewardship looking
at quality of productivity etc and we're
asking it in a way that not only ask but
some of our competitors are gonna go to
them and ask him the same way my job
basically you know big initiative was
because Unilever is a big customer of
ours and so they basically set out a
very clear metric that they wanted you
know 80% super certified sugar by 2014
so they they turned to me and say ok
make it happen
like I was supposed to do that by myself
of course I can't because it's lots of
changes that need to be made to do that
so but what what I can do is to as I
interact with other other customers
besides Unilever is to encourage them to
make the same demands because I'm a
strong believer in the
subjects of tipping point that what
becomes you know the radical voice in
the wilderness turns into the new norm
and so actually that's a subcommittee
that I actually stood on in Bonsu Grove
is to actually work on increasing the
demand side because if I can increase
the demand side of putting together a
larger stable of food companies that
care about these things then I can go
all the way to the other side which is
to our mill partners or we buy sugar
from around the world to say you need to
get your farm you know your suppliers
you know the farms that that feed the
mills bang Sukho certified so that we
can meet the demands of our customers
that's a lot of people and this is what
the NGOs become critical as well because
oftentimes you need you need really
identified projects and other and money
to be able to identify the gaps to close
them so they can actually get
certification so it's a lot it's a lot
of moving parts and the consumer demand
is simple it's actually probably the
part that it's no silent because it's
because the brands will respond to what
the consumers want and the consumers
don't don't aren't screaming they become
pretty passive I dad from the NGO
standpoint
Diane alluded to it you know the money
aspect looking at all the certification
schemes you know to jumpstart it the
suppliers who are certified will demand
a premium the end-users who are
demanding certified products do not want
to pay a premium everybody always wants
more money and it's a matter of seeing
who's gonna jump into the pool first and
who's gonna make that first public
commitment we saw it in palm oil where I
think it was Johnson and Johnson by a
very small amount of palm oil they said
we're going to buy 100% RSPO serve
certified palm oil or certificates once
they did that it was a snow
effect and getting that first person
through through the door is is going to
really push others to follow and on top
of that the other challenge is having a
commodity that it's quote hidden people
see something like palm oil and they
immediately associate with deforestation
you see sugar cane you don't immediately
associate it with really much anything
other than some of the dietary issues
that are in the news today you don't
associate it with water pollution or
some of the labor issues around the
world so hidden ingredients and the
first one to go through the door I think
are the big challenges no being just
taking from I think what kevin was just
saying on sugar there's so many other
key commodities that were able to really
move a lot further faster on when it
comes to sustainability endeavors
because we can promote it to the
consumer in a way where like cocoa we do
a lot with fair trade with rainforest
alliance even our own kind of standards
that we set we label that right on our
brands and we promote what we're doing
on it but with sugar it's not
necessarily an ingredient want to
promote on your product that you're
doing it you don't even want to bring
attention that there's sugar in some of
your products so it is one where you
know if there's an investment to be made
companies love to get that ROI right
back when you're going to the consumer
and on sugar again it's a difficult one
because it's one of the one of the
commodities that they don't like to
promote that's even in the brand
I mean product
I think we're in the problem I think I
think it's a core necessity right now it
used to be that we have to take action
to address some of the the risks that we
know are coming up in agriculture in the
future so we have got to be involved in
initiatives like Bonsu crow but as far
as really pushing it forward and getting
the funding that's needed getting you
know being one of those firsts to take
that jump today we're gonna buy these
certificates that's I think we're
working at we're working with all of our
suppliers we're encouraging them to get
bond super certified to go through all
this work but it's hard that's at that
like the inside of waiting for that
tipping point where it's okay to mention
that there's sugar hidden something and
I move forward
well we just sell sugar that's all week
that's all we do I mean it's a
nutritionist it's all bad for you I
think for many Lakota many titles before
always we find sugars aren't or not are
not healthy but I think writers kind of
like with its people wanna stop
consuming sugar it's in so many it's a
necessary ingredient in many foods I
mean like you can't really make you know
normal ice cream without without sugar I
mean it's a it's a it's a cheap source
of calories in many parts many parts of
the world it has all those problems but
it's also a cash crop it brings a lot of
money into places where there'd be
objective without the sugar industry so
those are the things that help me sleep
at night but in terms of it the dietary
cost yes they are there and they're real
I was gonna sit is the fact it's part of
I mean especially Mondelez international
the brands that would fall under our
company now are you know under biscuit
it's all the cookies and crackers and
chocolate candies and it gone I would
say but so it is a critical ingredient
for us we look at so our wellness
foundation it's part of our
sustainability initiatives and we're
looking at ways that we can we can make
consumers better aware and understand
you know what the what it is they're
eating letting them know on our labeling
initiatives on our marketing initiatives
and then even how we're packing it so I
know it wasn't a big deal but switching
over even to the 100 calorie pack things
those type of initiatives just to help
consumers beware of what they're in
taking and so it's all in moderation
we perceive do this for a more healthful
sweetener and also Beauregard ethically
friendly and how that has affected
well I would say looking at trends from
a sugar cane standpoint that were
there's always going to be a need to
engage on sugar cane looking at what a
lot of companies are doing and in terms
of reducing the amount of sugar in their
products nevertheless affluence is going
up and as affluence goes up around the
world people eat more sugar and as we
talked about last week we're looking by
2030 2040 I think somewhere around 265
million tonnes in global demand based on
affluence Inc and population growth
so while stevia you know stevia is a new
technology and the biggest challenge
with stevia is getting the blends right
if you look at what the beverage
industry is reporting they're not
getting really shelf-stable blends that
people like to drink yet so until they
get the science right about around
something like that has that has the
potential to be less impactful then
we're gonna still need to work on sugar
cane and there's still gonna be a great
demand for sugar cane do we as WWF think
that there's a great potential in
something like that to reduce impacts in
places that we care about yes because
you get a much more concentrated
sweetness from a smaller area of land
and a smaller amount of water however we
know that in the short term we've got
another 10 20 years of needing the
address sugar cane and on top of that
sugar cane will always be needed in the
probably the next 3040 years for a
biofuel standpoint biofuels for
packaging and fuels so
oh is that a the GMA grocery
manufacturers food whatever to me mmm I
whatever organization they have a
sustainability summit every year and I
was there last September and it was the
first time I had been to that particular
meeting of stunts very very well
excellent speakers all the big boys are
there and girls and basically when they
first started that they were making the
case for sustainability now they've
actually moved to the realizing that
anytime they've put sustainability
initiatives into their into their
companies basically they find that it
pays for itself very quickly because any
time pretty much any time you measure
anything whether it's in the public
school system and measuring how students
do mean and how teachers do you know
measuring you know what the energy cost
of this building would be people always
find inefficiencies that ultimately they
find cost reductions and the big
surprise is it owned engineering across
a goose I'm saving money in the long
term so but they've also come to a
conclusion that they decided based on
the research and they lived in a lot of
it that you've got about five percent of
consumers that care a lot you know we
should look at the pecked you know
parking lots and Whole Foods and there's
a few people another maybe ten percent
that care somewhat and then there's a
lot that if there's no price
differential by happy to buy something
that makes them feel good but the
majority of consumers just don't really
care and so they decided that they
weren't going to wait for them to care
they were going to work on some
initiatives a relevant event but to get
to the next level i i'm i'm a lil stimmy
as to how you get to that next level
where the consumer will then can make
demands of their
of the people that they spend their
money on they will be voting with their
dollars maybe you have ideas well I was
gonna say and a lot of I think so we're
in we're in organizations with like
Unilever PepsiCo coca-cola General Mills
Kellogg's there's one called the
sustainable AG initiative and we're
really trying to raise the bar across
the board and on what we're doing on all
of the core commodities that we're
buying so we're talking a lot about
sugar today but across the board we have
to have a minimum standard that and how
we're measuring it and how what our
commitments are and even there are a lot
of percentages out there and companies
are putting out there I could see right
now in Mondelez has a commitment to
sustainably source all of its key raw
materials and then you look at the
asterisks of what are the key raw
materials and that's what all of the
companies are doing they're saying we'll
be a hundred percent by 2020 what does
that mean and that's what really what
we're trying to get to by these by these
organizations that we're forming
together we're trying to work in an on a
pre-competitive way to say let's make
this let's stay focused and what the
purpose of this is about let's try not
to get away from it and and stay focused
on actually having a transformational
impact and and I think the other
commodities have shown us that it's
possible we've gotten so far like Kevin
said on palm oil that was a key one that
has proven the ability of industry to
help work together because one stepped
out and others are following so with
sugar we're at that point right now I
think we've all kind of signed up
through the sustainable AG initiative
we've all agreed this minimum standard
and then we're being held to it so
there's gonna start to be actual you
know reporting on are these companies
following through and what they said
because there were companies that made
statements back in 2010 and five years
later you go back and you see where they
were on it and and sometimes it's just a
lot of
so it's really making sure we're
following through the whole thing I have
a question for you right like how it is
like like if Walmart who buys who's
basically buys your products right to
put on the shelf how much do their
decisions impact yours they have a
significant impact over ours so it is
better if we are proactive and we bring
to them great ideas like hey you should
be asking about Bonsu grow we'll make
sure it's in our supply chain it would
help if you carry that through versus
waiting and being reactive to what they
come out with so depending on where
they're at on certain initiatives we
absolutely try to inform them so it's
again in our benefit to proactively try
to form these industry groups be members
of these industry groups and and then
sell up to those that are buying from us
before they turn around and tell us how
to do it yeah I would add on that point
the point that sherry was discussing
earlier in terms of Walmart and their
ability to move the market Walmart has
such an influence on companies it's
uncanny
they're 20% of consumer goods in the US
and take for instance coca-cola the
person in charge of the Walmart account
at coca-cola is the CEO of coca-cola
they don't have that relationship with
anybody else where Walmart calls up coke
and they have a problem the CEO picks up
that's how influential they are so it's
both a sort of it's a huge power and
sort of and it's a responsibility that
Walmart needs to take very seriously and
then the other issue that we've been
discussing up here is you know how do
you move the market one of the
challenges and this goes to what what I
am is saying about who cares in the u.s.
there is a significant percentage of
people who care you talk about sugar
around the world it's the eighth largest
source of calories and in places like
yeah where it's a human right and in
places like Mexico and Southern Africa
where it's a significant source of
calories you're dealing with very
impoverished people very impoverished
consumers who aren't going to say well
coca-cola is BOM sucrose certified and
Pepsi isn't so I'm gonna buy coca-cola
that's just not something that really
crosses the consumer mind in some of the
developing countries you mean supplies
you mean like the suppliers and the
growers of the sugarcane thanks or is
that well we were actually all of us
were in Colombia recently to basically
give presentations to picanha which is
the Colombian sugar sugar cane growers
we will be doing the same kind of horse
and pony show in Mexico City in in July
and part of that is to give voice to the
to let them know what you know
predominantly the American but big
global food companies are wanting to
prepare them for what's next you know
and sometimes the first time that
they're hearing about it's really a
window into both worlds but then we also
get to hear from them which is as that
goes we mention which is the which is
somewhat ok you want these things but
you know put some money on the table to
make it happen so there has to be a
concept of shared cost and shared
benefit so communication is really and
Trust is really critical there's also
lots of not a lot of trust sometimes
between the growers and the Millers
there frequently
you know there's strikes all the time in
some places the proportion of money that
the growers get is faced is government
controlled there's some not such great
history I mean sugar itself as that does
not had a very good history just in
terms of you know slavery around the
world so some of those inherent
historical tensions prevent them from
really working together as partners so
part of our job even then is to get to
get some of them that bring them to the
table even though that word is coming as
guests to their folks to their country
and I think if you went back
I remember having discussions in Mexico
with our suppliers in 2005 and actually
I think discussions on the better
sugarcane initiative at the time had
started but even at that time or 2004 it
was so it was very difficult because you
were coming in with your company's
standards and it felt even though the
standards and foundation upon which
Bonsu grow is based you look at as far
as labor rights you're looking at the
ILO principles when you're looking at
environmental standards etc those are
all things that as a company we upheld
but we were going in as our company and
we needed to then conduct audits
ourselves and the next day they were
gonna have coca-cola come and do the
same thing the next day they were gonna
have Unilever do the same thing and the
big difference was they didn't feel like
an owner we were having to control it
and we were kind of and we're forcing
something upon them so even though there
all these benefits that we thought for
sure they would see by going through the
process they weren't able to own it and
really control it and therefore make it
sustainable and so I think the
discussion has changed so much in
something like bongsook Row where it's a
multi stakeholder collaborative
initiative where the producer themselves
the farmer is given a seat at the table
to help inform how to go about doing
this what are the best methods and
they're then not having to go through
the cost of of their time and having all
those audits but they control it and and
just empowering them to
maybe you know a member but actually
they know we sugar farming far better
than we do so putting that that control
there has made the discussion far
greater and the information that you're
gathering it enables it to be a
sustainable initiative I just add that
with the multi-stakeholder approach one
of the things that growers really like
to see is the interest from end-users
whenever I go anywhere with Mondelez or
coca-cola and we go out into a sugarcane
field they're very excited to see where
their product goes because when they
last see what they did it's a it's a
giant piece of grass getting hauled off
to a mill and then when they see it in a
can of coke or a can of Pepsi it means
something to them it's sort of like the
fruits of their labor come to bear and
when they see someone interested in
improving the way that what improving
the manner in which they behave or they
perform that that gets them excited as
well they become part of something
bigger so that that's one of the the
nice things about these multi
stakeholder approaches
well they're looking I mean the two
approaches right now in the wellness or
well-being platforms as part of the
sustainability initiatives are the
labeling and the packaging but also just
how to make the products more healthful
so I agree and yes there are great
opportunities I think when you know if
they really look at the amount of real
sugar going into the products if they
could identify and label it it's really
getting the brand to want to promote
that and that's again only if you need
that pull from the consumer side if you
want to put on there the certification
that says you know this is made from
sugar that you know it's sustainably
sourced and and I think it's that
consumer that understands it that would
readily kind of want to purchase that if
there are pants purchasing calling for
sugar versus I think there's that fear
of just calling attention to fact that
there's sugar in my product again so
it's at that I guess
balancing point and we have to make sure
that we're gonna be doing it whether or
not we can sell it as a low gaan front
of pack just as a caveat we also do a
lot of Fairtrade products and with that
there's you know spare straight sugar
every ingredient that can be fair trade
must be fair trade when you buy a fair
trade marked product and so work a lot
and and again we usually call out
attention to the work that we're doing
and all the other ingredients except for
sugar and it's again at risk even in the
Fairtrade world so so if that is an area
that you're studying it would be great
to hear your views on it
there's a good amount of work that's
been done with salt to see how to see
how much you can pare it down before you
start to change I personally can't say
yes or no but I can say that we
absolutely are always looking at our
spec our specifications for our products
to look how you can again make the
product right now there's a focus on how
we can make it more helpful so I would
hope that that would be part of it
obviously - there'd be a cost savings if
you're reducing some key but if there's
a substitute I'm not sure yes it's so
often times when they what mostly
consumer grants are concerned about is
you know customer satisfaction that
people like the way it tastes and
unfortunately very often you know
sweeter is there's just a lot more this
has higher performance you know from
from consumers who taste it can you be
trained a consumer I think yogurt is
actually very interesting and what
yogurt first came out a long time ago
cuz I'm really old you know nothing this
yogurt was like you know like like
something like Mike my Greek family maid
on the Brady yogurt comes out and they
they put like tons of sugar in it right
it was so sweet and that's what people
got used to consuming all the time so
what happens now all of a sudden we have
like Greek yogurt right and they took
the sugar out of it you know and now
they're probably gonna put it all back
in again you know so it's how you eat
and how you train yourself or you don't
pills and even even with the Greek
yogurt craze going on there are it goes
back to how do we optimize our food
system because with Greek yogurt versus
you know regular yogurt regular yogurt
has more inputs but the outputs are
different you get a lot more waste water
than you have to
in Greek yogurt than anything else and
that's a real challenge for the four or
five plants in the u.s. they're just
churning this stuff out as quickly as
they can
how do you manage that because there's
no infrastructure to deal with it it's
not something we can't solve but we have
to think about it in these types of food
systems approaches how do you make sure
that so it's pump for you
so first I'll briefly I think I've been
involved with Vaughn sucrose since the
almost the beginning of when we got
serious about becoming a standard first
we decided it was going to be a metric
standard so we didn't tell anyone they
had to do something it's it's a
performance benchmark figure out in your
own ingenuity how to get there so if
you're an Indian sugarcane farmer who
uses vermicompost on your one hectare
versus a Brazilian sugarcane farmer with
5,000 hectares do it your own way that's
the starting principle then there then
there are sort of two other steps that
go in you bring together all these
stakeholders from around the world and
have consultations around the world
you figure you have your standard you go
out and pilot it and make sure it's not
impossible for everyone then you set the
standard because you also want standards
are sort of designed to go towards
comparative advantage in some places you
probably shouldn't be growing sugarcane
like in the deserts of Peru and then
then what we also have are programs
where we co-invest with sugarcane
farmers these are members of
sucre hukou invest funds to move them to
that higher level of performance so
solidary Dodd a Dutch NGO does an
amazing job with this they bring a lot
of money from the Dutch development aid
agency and they co-invest with farmers
they do a cost share program and that
really helps move people over the bar
sure
so 2005 or 2006 I can't remember the
exact date there's a meeting in London
assembled by WWF and the International
Finance Corporation brought together
about 2530 stakeholders some farmers
brands traders you name it and they
decided that in there to start an
initiative to address the environment to
one to build consensus around what the
impacts were from an environmental and
social standpoint and then create a
standard it took them three years to
agree on using the word standard and
from there it's been a rollercoaster so
yeah one word can cause a lot of
problems so don't ever let anyone tell
you words don't matter one of the things
that I was most I've been most impressed
about Bonsu crow and how I think it's
enabled it to be a standard of integrity
is because of the way they assured they
went out to such a wide they cast the
net I guess across all potential
stakeholders even their methodology of
how how they put out online for the once
we put together the standards they hired
experts within each area so if you have
productivity quality human rights labor
rights environment etc and you had
people in charge of each of those kind
of working groups and streams and they
opened up opportunity for every
stakeholder help feed back into it then
they shut down the dates by when you can
feed back they were able to kind of
bring all the information together and
then put it back out there and there was
enough time enough notice and I think
the even the use of all the different
social mediums they were able to assure
that all of those key stakeholders had
the opportunity to feedback so you feel
like you have a standard that from the
farmer all the way through to the ILO to
even competing certifications like
rainforest Lions fair trade they were
all invited to feedback into it so I
feel it's one of the most robust as as
far as standards go really has that type
of I guess integrity behind it um it
took a lot of time but I think that time
that was spent was well worth it it's
also I'm very metric based I mentioned I
used to be director of quality so I've
been part of a lot of quality audits and
maybe some of you are familiar with the
organization called down AIB which was a
organisation from the baking industry
that was responsible for doing the
quality audits for that peanut company
that got everyone who is sick with
salmonella several years ago and the
owner of the company ended up being you
know prosecuted for criminal behavior
even though he had been audited by an
accredited auditing company but but this
this this audit was basically you know
satisfactory not satisfactory a lot of
it was done in an office building to
make sure they had the right procedures
but very little going out into the plant
and seeing what was actually being done
so those kind of audits can kind of get
a stamp of approval but they don't
really mean a whole lot and they don't
even do what what what Vasu ko does
which is that con which which measures
constant improvement so with bon sucrose
standard farmers can measure themselves
against their elder cohorts you know
locally and globally to see how how
they're doing so I think it's phenomenal
it prevents things from getting fuzzy
and gray and
you're sure it has its challenges like
you articulated that how does the same
standard play in different countries but
those are conversations that are always
going on good
I have to apologize everyone I've got to
catch a flight to Brazil tonight all
right thanks a lot everyone
my thing because of the roots of because
WWF was one of the original founders for
Bonsu crow they were able to bring in a
lot of the learnings and I think a lot
of the key members industry members like
ourselves were members of both so RSPO I
think the lesson learned was trying to
gain consensus waiting for consensus
before moving forward on something and
it that felt like the longest initiative
that I think anyone that was on it ever
participated in
so when bond super came around won the
whole idea of making a metric based
getting it out of the gate from the
onset that we wanted to do this as
setting it as a standard and you know
letting that work itself out but then
again how it went out as far as setting
the standard they purposefully looked
for experts in each area like I
mentioned before and they opened up a
period of time where you could feed in
where you could flood those experts and
you know suggested use of standards and
measurements and methodologies and then
shut down that time period and then open
to back up for feedback and then shut it
back again and really you had your
chance to say your piece and then it was
done and we moved forward on it there
wasn't a need for a hundred percent
consensus it was seen as you know what
we're gonna go with this and in two
years they opened up again for review I
think that was the one of the key
learnings of of it was you cannot wait
for everybody around the table to agree
to absolutely everything or it will take
forever because you can't even get past
the semantics like you said as far as it
that's one lesson but there's a lot of
positive - I think we saw that it was
possible with palm oil and so sugar
seems like it's a huge monster a lot of
times but
seemed like if we could do it palm oil
then we can do it with sugarcane
actually plays out in terms on the
production and what it actually looks
like because so of the certified members
according to the website it's only like
about six percent are our farmers so I'm
wondering is it that the farmers are out
of it and they're out of them by the
mills who or who have the certification
and the mills are responsible for
compliance from their pro from their
farmers is that kind of the model that
it works by or yeah to the model so that
correct me if I'm wrong but the model is
that the mill is the owner
so the mill has to be certified and then
part of their certification includes the
farms from which they're they're buying
and sometimes the mill and a lot of
countries the mill owns the farms so
it's one in the same but in other
countries where it's farmers selling to
the mills like Mexico that's where the
farmers would also they have to audit
all the different farms that are
percentage of those farms that are
supplying to them there is a movement
right now to enable farmers themselves
to become fond sucrose certified and
then sell up or try to get the mills to
be certified and sell through them so
right now as a standard holds it's a
mill owned initiative and they're
responsible for certifying the farms
there are farmers like in Colombia that
would like to that it feel more
empowered and would like to certify
themselves as a collective whole and
then you know bring to the mill the fact
that they need to be certified and and
go that way but that's how it's started
off so a mill that revs the milk you
know put out puts out you know 200
thousand metric tons of sugar in a year
well if only twenty thousand metric tons
of that is certified land that the
farmers and
then they have mass balance so they can
it all comes into them into the mill you
can't really separate out you know the
difference of course you know sugar
canes dogs so they can sell 20% of their
output as certified and so a lot of the
original sugar came that's been
certified has been from large Brazilian
Mel's from their own land and now
they're working on getting the farmers
that also supply the same mills
certified but that's more difficult
because they just don't simply have as
much control over that and then also you
have just the simple risk they help some
farm get certified make the investment
and then the farm would go sell to their
the other mill next door so there's like
I said there's just some of those
stories going on and it's not all clean
and clear and that's why the more the
better their relationships the better
the initiatives can be going forward so
we're kind of peacemakers at the same
time clearly your short BIOS you both
have faith-based backgrounds and I'm
wondering how you see I don't want not
so much a personal question but how do
you see faith-based organizations
generally within the US or worldwide
being part of not necessarily the sugar
discussion but the sustainability
discussions or the food or the moral
discussions are surrounding these issues
well we don't get so many people that
admit or as part of their BIOS present
themselves this way so I thought
interesting it's a really good question
actually
we mentioned salad Aaron Dodd that's
actually an organization that was
founded in Liberation Theology in the
Catholic Church in South America back in
the 70s I believe something like that
and and they are now a Dutch based
company I don't know they're so they're
founded in a faith based you know
foundation I'm not sure they're so faith
based any longer but it's still the
foundation of who they are and they're
big they've been critically really
important to Bonsu grow their the muddy
boots on the ground
they're the ones who answer they're
getting for helping the farmers do the
you know do the work to get certified
they have money coming directly from
them from the Dutch government it's
that's feeding that is there any other
faith-based organizations I can't think
of any to you yeah I think even the
interface organization like right out in
in New York City they were a critical
stakeholder and even helping form the I
guess the they especially help to inform
a lot of the labor rights they're I
think one of the key advocates around
the world for Human Rights come from a
lot of the faith-based organizations as
well as the environmental stewardship I
would say I mean going back even to
Cadbury it was a Quaker own you know
Quaker family and so they based their
core values on stewardship and human
rights and being a force for good in the
world and so it became a key component
in any decision you didn't have to make
a business case for why you wouldn't buy
cocoa from a cocoa supplier that had
slave labor like it was it was an
obvious reason why you wouldn't but then
obviously I had to be transitioned out
and when we were acquired we had to
create those business cases as to why
and they're usually there is an obvious
business case to it but even in the u.s.
two weeks ago there was a huge
conference in Annapolis and we spent
several days going up to farms and in
Pennsylvania and Virginia and a lot of
the environmental initiatives are led by
some of the fellow faith-based
organizations led by the Mennonites etc
where it's part of their inherent belief
system and so there's this trust there
because it's part of the belief system
that they're to be stewards of the land
and the animals and those that work for
them and so I think that then growing
and and learning from it larger
companies like the Monsanto's that were
there they took in a lot and we're
bringing it back to the organization so
I think there's a it's it is out there
but like you said it's probably just not
gonna talk a lot
but if people I guess I guess my heart
probably just goes out to the children
you know some of the stories I've heard
like our original initiatives or some of
the programs are in Mexico because
that's where CSC just happens to have a
big footprint and you know we talk about
why can't the kids you know why don't
why are the kids still working on the
farms you know why aren't they and
someone shared the story about well the
schools are far away okay
Mexico isn't really a very safe place
for anybody to be in far you know in
lots of places then when they get to
school maybe maybe now the teacher shows
up okay and then maybe maybe now the
education is worth anything anyway and
then I hear stories about even like
sexual misconduct you know in the school
systems whether away from there you know
in these in these places so think about
it you know I'm up mom you know I have
three children when I think about
sending my sending my children off to go
to school with those risks it's like
probably not you're probably going to
keep them home on your on your farm it's
this probably a safer alternative so
that's why other organizations like Save
the Children Mexico you know and some
other organizations that are actually
they're working on pilot programs to
bring schools closer to where the farms
are to mitigate some of these risks is
really really important and so I feel
like anything and even if I could take
with help to bridge that gap I would
feel really really good for me it
probably wouldn't be the ideal it but I
would
love to see where there would be I
consider the standards that we agreed on
four bonds to grow to be a minimum like
a floor and so it would be great if if
it was you know that you cannot purchase
sugar unless it had that that fun super
standard you want to go above and beyond
that's great
but that that would be recognized as the
core minimum and just wouldn't even be a
second thought and you just see you know
across the board where you where we are
now maybe with food safety so certain
standards that are requisites now you
and even you cannot buy for law you can
buy certain things unless they had food
safety certification which so that would
be probably you know until we raise the
floor and you kind of need that out
there once that certification helps to
transform the industry and we're
operating at a level where human rights
are not being violated and because to
Diane's point there's those situations
like that and then they're situations
where the kids don't even have the
opportunity even if they had a great
school system somewhere down the road
they wouldn't even be allowed to go
because you know it's more of a horse
labor issue so there's a lot of
atrocities happening in the sugar cane
earlier the efficiencies that come along
with measuring production and also the
contribution that growers made to the
development of the standards I'm
wondering if you can speak to the
specifics of how they came up with the
actual numbers well I'm you know I'm a
little bit new to that's spun suit crow
you know it's been about a year so I'm
but in Colombia I know that one thing
that they came up in a lot of
conversations was water usage you know
in some places even there's this
irrigation in some places and their
irrigation and not where there is
irrigation the yields are just are just
much higher the year like we were in
Colombia coming at some of the highest
sugar yields in the world
they're upwards about 150 men to
remember that measurement isn't that
rather honest any 150 hollowly tons per
acre or whatever it might be which is
much which and in Mexico it's half so
those kind of things you'll be able to
see you know how much how much water can
increase yield another one is sugarcane
burning they burn sugarcane sometimes so
they don't have to you know bring all
that I mean all the stocks and
everything into the mills and that
creates a certain environmental hazard
as well so they're trying to work on
getting rid of the burning you know so
these are just steps or trying to take
so it's a percentage reduction of some
of those and also weed control weeds
also would have a huge impact on yields
so I think that's one place then mostly
familiar yeah when I think that focus on
yield especially for the farmer is so
important because if they can increase
they can increase yield on same land
mass then they're increasing their ROI
and so getting a more immediate ROI to
the farmer is by far the most critical
thing needed and it's the only way you
can ever move forward on a standard the
farmer has got to realize a more
immediate benefit we I think need to be
able to wait and absorb for a few years
until we see it
but I think we see it in our long term
supply chain there's no way that you can
project out you know in commodities and
not be working now and thinking ten
years ahead and so but the farmer needs
to feed their family tomorrow the next
day the next day and they've got to be
getting a benefit and if there's no
point in having them do any new
initiative that's only gonna come at a
cost to them and so I think really the
focus for us especially as it started
off it's still in its infancy stages has
been on looking at those productivity
measures and adopting environmental
environmentally sound ways of increasing
productivity and as they do that they
see the value in it
and they're generating greater yield I
think that's just one of the first key
wins there and things that the farmer
has been most empowered by and they're
starting a whole online forum in Bonn
super once you remember where you can
own what you can share your key
learnings with other farmers around the
world and that's another whole way where
farmers are helping other farmers around
the world growing sugarcane it's usually
in a tropical environment you know they
have the same type of systems and so
they can really be sharing key
information even aragón metrics about
you know like like in who someone cuts
someone carry someone you know separate
out those tests that'll make it more
efficient even those kind of learning is
having enormous impact and how much
labor you need on a farm so the point is
to release the children from having to
work without impacting the economics of
the fire
we harvest Ernie and so a lot of at
least between paper on the that ship to
the mechanization and in Brazil and
doing the no sugar cane harvest it's no
turn is shifting to transdimensional
harvesting to Mecca next privacy you
know you get a lot of them by our mental
benefits in terms of reduced emissions
and air quality but then also it's the
machine itself put so many workers out
of work so how in terms of the social
issue how would things better people to
because you're paying is such a
intensive job and there's a lot of human
rights issues with just is the answer to
entirely the good plan was actually we
were to sell last yeah aristocrat mark
and there was actually a gentleman from
the University who presented a paper
basically talking about you know how was
the economic impact of law recognizing
harvesting now of course in some places
is too rocky too hilly to really use it
so it doesn't really increase efficiency
so much but it certainly can eliminate
some of the labor issues to kind of
solve one to perhaps create another now
he was claiming that with the retraining
that over time they now they're becoming
you know a tractor driver instead of
cane cutter but over the time that
you're actually it's a better better
life but you know in the minima in the
beginning it's gonna be a disruption and
I'll take a while to absorb that but I
think the analogy would be you know that
our America I mean you know we mechanize
harvest pretty much everything and no
one would say well let's go back to the
old days when we had people
with skies you know cutting down you
know wheat so I think it's just it's
just part of it is progress but Columbia
was actually really interesting because
in Cali in order to kind of break the
back of the drug industry their sugar
cane became a way of doing that so they
actually wanted to employ as many people
as possible so that you were basically
able to like give people something else
to do besides grow cocaine so it's just
interesting each country and its own
stories but it's a fascinating
conversation I mean we're all we're all
paying attention closely yeah and some
of the companies are working with dance
that are moving towards mechanization
that is their focus they so there are
kind of being held - are you going to be
retraining a lot of the farmers if
that's gonna be if your job is now
eliminated you know it's I guess from
the Industrial Revolution extent as
certain jobs were eliminated are we they
going to train up or not and and so it
is another one of those key metrics that
we have to add and start to measure
because already advocacy groups are out
there looking at that and I think it's
great if that's part of your study
because I think Brazil is showing us the
key you know there are a lot of
countries that are going to follow
Brazil is a huge leader in sugarcane so
paper yeah